will my right-hand friend agree to meet
with me and throw the weight of the
government
behind the efforts to make sure that gsk
does the right thing by my constituents
and delivers for some very worried
people yes
prime minister i thank my honourable
friend very much and i want to
express my deepest sympathy to all those
in albus and affected by
uh these job losses and to say that i
will certainly
meet with him i believe that bioscience
is one of the great
growth areas uh for this country in the
future and i am determined uh that
barrow
uh and furness should uh take part in
that uh boom
along with everywhere else as well as
other high technologies
right let's come to the leader of the
opposition kia stammer
thank you mr speaker can i join the
prime minister's comments about some
patrick's day
my thoughts and i'm sure those across
the whole of the house
are with the family and friends of sarah
everard who will be suffering
unspeakable grief there are five words
that will stick with us for a very long
time she was just walking home
sometimes a tragedy is so shocking it
demands both
justice and change the stephen lawrence
case
showed the poison of structural and
institutional racism
the james bulger case made us question
the nature of our society
and the safety of our children now the
awful events of the last week have
lifted a veil
on the epidemic of violence against
women and girls
this must also be a watershed moment to
change how we as a society
treat women and girls and how we prevent
and end sexual violence and harassment
i believe that if we work together we
can achieve that
and the questions i ask today are in
that spirit so first does the prime
minister agree
that this must be a turning point in how
we tackle violence against women and
girls
mr speaker yes i do and i
associate myself fully with the uh
remarks the right normal gentleman has
made
about the appalling murder of sarah
everard i'm sure that
those emotions are shared in this house
and
around the country and that event has
triggered a
reaction that i believe is wholly
justified and understandable and of
course
we in government are doing everything
that uh
we can we're investing in uh the crime
prosecution service trying to
uh speed up the law we're changing the
law on
uh domestic violence and and many many
other things
but i think that he is right frankly
that unless and until
we have a change in our culture that
acknowledges
and understands that women currently
do not feel they are being heard we will
not
fix this problem and that is what we
must do we need a
cultural and social change in attitudes
to redress the balance mr speaker
and that is what i believe all
politicians must now work together
to achieve kirsten can i thank the prime
minister for that answer in that spirit
can i turn to the practical challenges
we face if we are
collectively to rise to this moment
the first challenge mr speaker is that
many many women and girls
feel unsafe on our streets particularly
at night
what's needed is legal protection
and that's why we've called for a
specific new law on street harassment
and also for toughening the law on
stalking both i think are
absolutely vital if we're going to make
meaningful change
in the everyday experiences of women and
girls
so can the prime minister commit to take
both of these measures forward
mr speaker we're always happy to look at
uh new proposals
uh what we're already doing is
introducing tougher sanctions
uh on stalkers uh or that's already been
uh been brought in and we're bringing in
new measures uh
to make the streets safer of course
that's the right thing to do mr speaker
last night there was a a bill before the
the house on police crime and sentencing
which did a lot uh to protect women and
girls which did a lot to protect women
and girls and it would have been good in
a
uh a cross-party way mr speaker to have
had the support of the opposition
kirsten mr speaker i'll come to last
night's bill
later but he did say a lot more about
protecting statues
than it did about protecting women
but but but let me if i may given the
gravity of the situation continue
continuing the
spirit so far and i thank the prime
minister for his answer
the next challenge practical challenge
is that many many women and girls who
are subjected to
sexual violence do not feel confident to
come forward and report what has
happened to them
nine out of ten don't do so
we have to support we have to improve
the support that's provided
for victims the victims commissioner
published a report last month with 32
recommendations about this this week
labour produced a detailed survivor
support plan
and five years ago i introduced a
private member's bill
with cross-party support for a victims
law to give legally enforceable rights
to victims
the shadow victims minister my
honourable friend from hove
has tabled a similar victims bill that's
before parliament now
it's ready to go all it needs is
political will to act so will the prime
minister commit now not just to the idea
of
victims law which i think he does
support but to a tight timetable ideally
six months or so to actually implement
such a law
prime minister uh as i say mr speaker
we're very happy to look at
uh new proposals uh from uh all sides of
the house
on this issue and that's why we're
conducting an end-to-end
uh review of the of the law and rape and
how it works and
uh investing in the criminal justice
system to speed up cases
and give women and girls the confidence
that they need and i think that
the point he makes about uh victims
and uh their need to feel confident in
coming forward is
absolutely right and that's why we've
put 100 million pounds so far
into the services for dealing with
violence against women
and girls particularly independent
domestic violence advisers independent
sexual violence advisers mrs b i don't
pretend
that these are the entire solution they
are part of the solution
but it is also vital mr speaker that we
have long
term cultural societal change to deal
with this issue
thank you mr speaker i agree with the
prime minister on that last point
c can i gently remind him that for ten
years this government has been promising
a victim's law
i think it's been in his party's last
three manifestos
it still hasn't materialized we don't
promise to need more reviews
consultation strategies
the conversations our shadow minister is
having with government constructed
conversations
are exactly the same conversations as i
had five years ago constructed
conversations
we just need now to get on with it but
let me press on with the the practical
challenges
because the next challenge is this that
for many many women and girls who do
come forward
to report sexual violence no criminal
charges abroad
only 1.5 percent of rapes reported to
the police
lead to a prosecution put the other way
98.5 percent of reported rapes
don't lead to a prosecution that's a
shocking statistic
i do appreciate that efforts are being
made to improve the situation
but can the prime minister tell us what
is he going to do about this
not in a few years time not next year
but now prime minister
he's entirely right mr speaker in the
sense that
i i agree with him one of the first
things i said uh when i became prime
minister was that i believe that the
prosecution
rates for rape were a disgrace in this
in this country and uh we need to
to sort it out and yes that's why we're
investing in uh confidence building
measures such as
uh isba's and uh and adverbs and
investing in the uh in the
in the cps and trying to speed up the
process of the
of the law to give people the confidence
their cases will be heard uh in due time
uh but we're also doing uh what we can
to
toughen the penalties for those men and
i'm afraid it is
overwhelmingly men who commit these
crimes and
i think it would have been a good thing
uh if last night the whole house could
have voted
uh for tougher sentences uh for those
who commit
sexual and violence offensive offenses
and stop
uh stop people mr speaker from being
released early and
in that collegiate spirit i would ask
him to work together with us
mr speaker i was director of public
prosecution for five years and spent
every day prosecuting serious crime
including terrorism sexual violence and
rape so
i really don't need lectures about how
to enforce the criminal law
but walking on through the system as
many women and girls have to do
and facing up to the challenges that we
need to face up to a house
as a house the next challenge is the
point the prime minister just referenced
and that's the sentences for rape
and sexual violence because they need to
be toughened
let me give the house three examples
john john john patrick convicted of
raping a 13 year old girl
he received a seven year sentence
orlando and constanza convicted of
raping a woman in a nightclub
they received a seven and a half year
sentence james reeve
convicted of raping a seven-year-old
girl he received a nine-year sentence
does the prime minister agree we need
urgently to look at this
and to toughen sentences for rape and
serosexual violence
prime minister mr speaker wouldn't it be
a wonderful thing if there was a bill
uh going through the house of commons uh
which did
exactly that uh wouldn't it be a
wonderful thing if there were measures
to defend women and girls from violent
and sex criminals uh tough wouldn't it
be a wonderful thing if there was a bill
before the house
uh to have tougher sentences for child
murderers
and tougher tougher punishments for sex
offenders that i think would be a fine
thing
as it happens as it happens there is
such a bill
before the house i think it would be a
great thing if the right honorable
gentleman
actually had voted for it uh he still
has titan this bill is still
before the house he can lift his
opposition they actually voted against
it mr speaker on a three-line whip and i
think it was crazy
mr speaker he mentions the bill last
night
that provided for longer maximum
sentences for damaging a memorial
than the sentences imposed in the three
cases of rape i've
heard i've referred the house to all of
those sentences less than 10 years
i thank the prime minister i thank the
prime minister for providing me with the
best examples
of why the priorities in his bill were
so wrong and nothing in that bill
would have increased the length of
sentence in any of those rape
cases nothing in that bill but let me
try to
return to the constructive spirit
because i think that is demanded of all
of us
if this house came together on the
points raised today
and there's been agreement across the
dispatch boxes
it would make a real difference to
victims of crime
this week labour published a 10-point
plan we published a victims law
in coming days we're going to publish
amendments in relation to the criminal
justice system to make it work better
now i don't expect the prime minister to
agree with all of this
and frankly i don't care if this becomes
a government bill
or conservative legislation all i care
about is whether we make progress
so will the prime minister meet me the
shadow home secretary
the honourable member for birmingham
yardley and victims groups who've
spent many years campaigning on this so
that we can really
and truly make this a turning point
prime minister
mr speaker he i'm afraid that he does uh
and i'm grateful to him for
uh the the collegiate speed way in which
he's addressing this and
the way in which he's he's reaching out
across the chamber i think that's
entirely right
in the circumstances but i i do think
that uh
he should not misrepresent what the bill
was trying to do the average sentence
for rape is already
nine years nine months as he knows uh
full well that
the maximum sentence is is already life
what we were trying to do
is stiffen the sentences for a variety
of offenses
offenses to protect women and girls and
others and that is entirely
the right thing to do mr speaker and we
will go on with our agenda delivering on
other people's priorities rolling out uh
more police
uh 7 000 we have already investing in is
version it wasn't
doing our utmost to accelerate the
processes the grinding processes
of the criminal justice system which as
he rightly says are such a deterrent
uh to women in coming forward uh to
complain as they
as they rightly should uh but until we
sort out that fundamental problem
until women feel that they are being
heard and their voices are being heard
and their complaints
are being addressed by society we'll we
will not fix this problem
and i warmly welcome uh what he suggests
about wanting to fix it
together and i hope that in that spirit
he can bring himself to vote for the
tougher sentences that we've set out
[Music]
just to say we've got to be a little bit
careful because nobody will misrepresent
each other in this south state double
thank you mr speaker can i thank the
prime minister for bringing the g7
leader summit to cornwall
this summer this will put cornwall front
and center of the world stage
as we emerge from the pandemic and give
us a great opportunity
to showcase all that cormor has to offer
not just as a great place to visit and
our amazing food and drink sector
but in the technologies of the future in
space and renewable energy
i know the prime minister shares my
ambition that the g7 will leave a
lasting economic
legacy for the people of cornwall so to
that end in light of the recent progress
made on lithium extraction
would he work with me to secure a
gigafactory
for cornwall so that we can produce the
batteries leave that lasting
economic legacy and provide the
well-paid jobs for the future that
cornwell needs yes
prime minister yes of course mr speaker
i think uh cornwall is the klondike of
of lithium as far as i uh i understand
the the matter and i'll be delighted to
assist him in
uh in locating a a gigafactory
uh somewhere near cornwall uh mr speaker
but i don't want to
i don't want to promise too much at this
stage
let's go to the leader of the smp ian
blackford
and thank you mr speaker and can i wish
everyone a happy saint patrick's day
mr speaker for people across scotland
this week again exposed a tale of two
governments
with two very different sets of values
yesterday the snp government passed
landmark legislation
that will put the un convention on the
rights of the child
into scots law putting children
at the vanguard of children's rights
in contrast we have a uk government that
has to be shamed into providing
free school meals that will clap for
nurses
but won't give them a fair wage and
plows
billions into a nuclear arsenal that
sits redundant
on the clyde does the prime minister
understand
that the scottish people are best served
with a government that lives up to their
values
a government prime minister that
prioritizes
bears not bombs
i'm british i think what the people of
scotland need and deserve mr speaker
is a government that tackles the
problems of education
uh in scotland uh that addresses itself
to fighting crime
and drug addiction in scotland and a
government
in scotland that weans itself of its
addiction uh to constitutional
change and constitutional argument and
he seems determined
to call her in the middle of a pandemic
when the country is trying to move
forward
together seems determined and obsessed
with nothing else mr speaker
nothing else than breaking up the
country and a reckless
[Music]
in referendum in mr speaker thank you of
course this is prime minister's
questions
the prime minister maybe just once just
once
might start to try and answer the
question that's put down because we're
talking about a tory plan
to impose a 40 increase
in nuclear warheads our children
have the right to a future that no
longer lives under the shadow
of these weapons of mass destruction as
the irish president
said on this and patrick's day surely we
need to
find ways to make peace not war every
single one of these weapons
will be based on the clyde so can the
prime minister tell us exactly
when the scottish people gave him the
moral
or democratic authority to impose these
weapons of mass destruction
on our soil in scotland
mr speaker the uh people of scotland
uh contribute enormously to the health
happiness
well-being and security of this entire
country
not least through their contribution to
uh our science
our defenses uh our international aid
and many many other ways and i'm
very proud that this government is
investing record sums in
defense uh including maintaining our
nuclear defense which is absolutely
vital for our
long-term security and helping thereby
to
drive jobs not just uh in
uh in scotland but across the whole of
the uk
thank you mr speaker back in july last
year i informed the prime minister of
the need for a new hospital in doncaster
sadly doncaster was not mentioned in the
first 40 hospitals promised in the
manifesto
what the building of the further eight
specialist hospitals was
yet does my right honourable friend
agree with me that a new hospital
will prove to the people of doncaster
that this government is committed
to building back better and leveling up
their town
prime minister my honorable friend is a
fantastic advocate of doncaster and he's
he's right to
uh to campaign in the way that he he
does i wish i could
uh give him a uh you know a cut and
dried yes and yes or no answer
uh today but i can tell him that uh his
local trust is very much in the running
uh in the current open uh competition
for the next eight
hospitals on top of the 40 and mr
speaker that we're already building
let's go to caroline lucas caroline
thank you mr speaker the creation of a
no protest zone around parliament
a 266 increase from a maximum
three months to 11 months imprisonment
for protest organizers
a direct attack on the gypsy roma and
traveller community
up to 10 years in prison for any offence
committed by destroying
or damaging a memorial and criminalizing
people for taking part in protests where
they
ought to have known police conditions
were in place
would the prime minister agree that if
the uk is to be a force for good
in a world where democracy is in retreat
as his foreign secretary is saying today
it needs to start at home with the
protection of the long-standing
precious and fundamental right to
peaceful protest
that is a cornerstone of liberal
democracy
prime minister she is quite right
to uh stick up for peaceful protest and
uh i i understand that and i i
sympathize with that
uh but there are a couple of points
first of all we're facing a pandemic mr
speaker which we have to restrict uh
alas we have to
restrict human contact and and although
she shakes her head i think that the
people of this country do understand
that they do understand
the restrictions that we're now under
and i think we also have to strike a
balance between
the need to allow peaceful protest to go
ahead and we do
uh on a huge scale in this country but
also to protect
free speech mr mr speaker and vital
parts of the uk economy
thank you very much mr speaker i also
want to see the fundamental right to
protest protected
so events such as that powerful vigil uh
last saturday and clapham comma can
proceed safely including code safe
but i also want to see measures so
people can go about their lives get to
work get to hospital without being
hindered
so can the prime minister reassure me
that that police and crime bill which
we've been discussing today and was in
the house yesterday
does strike that balance whilst also
taking action against the perpetrators
of some of the worst crimes
prime minister uh my my honourable
friend has perfectly summed up the
balance that we're trying to
to strike between allowing people in a
reasonable way to go about their
their daily lives but also bringing in
tougher
sentences for uh for child murderers
tougher
punishments for sex offenders and
stopping the practice
the continual practice of allowing
people out early mr speaker i think
that's what the people of this country
uh want to see that's what they voted
for uh in 2019 and
i hope that uh the opposition can still
uh can bring themselves
uh one day to support it thank you mr
speaker
with the government's end-to-end rape
review remaining unpublished two years
after it was promised
rape conviction rates having fallen to
their lowest point on record and almost
90
of sexual harassment complaints not even
reported to the police
women are increasingly being left
without legal recourse for sexual
violence
i have parliamentary privilege i can
name the men who have hurt me
but millions of women in this country
don't even have that
stuck between a criminal system where
only 1.4 percent of reported offences
result in charges being laid
and where too many survivors who speak
out are pursued through the civil
courts by their abusers to silence them
can the prime minister advise how women
are meant to get justice
mr speaker i'm afraid that she's
completely right and i know that she
speaks for many people
many women up and down the the country
and what we need to do we can do all the
things that we've we've talked about
uh two men uh arguing over the dispatch
box we can do all those things we can
bring in
um more laws uh tougher sentences uh
which i hope she will
support we can uh support independent
domestic violence and sexual violence
advisors
all that kind of thing but we have to
address the fundamental issue
of the the casual everyday sexism
and apathy that fails to address the
concerns
of women that is the underlying issue
let's go to fiona bruce
fiona thank you mr speaker
two years ago the bishop of truro
produced an interim report
outlining the global phenomenon of
persecution of christians
as we make progress in our manifesto
commitment to fully implement the trua
review recommendations
does the prime minister join me in
looking forward to our hosting
the international ministerial conference
on freedom of religion or belief next
year
and to the uk demonstrating its global
leadership
in defending and promoting this
universal right for all
prime minister i thank my honorable
friend very much for everything that
she's doing to campaign for freedom of
religion and
and belief and i'm very pleased that
we're going to be holding
an international conference on this
issue that is exactly what
global britain is all about it's about
promoting freedom of expression
freedom of belief and religion let's go
to peter graham
peter thank you mr speaker
the prime minister refused point blank
to answer the question from my
very honourable friend from ghost guy in
la cambo so i'll ask him again
what is it that gives any british prime
minister the moral and democratic right
to impose the obscenity of an even
bigger arsenal
of weapons of mass murder on the people
of scotland
against their express will
prime minister uh mr speaker i think
that was a veiled attempt
again by the uh
uh the snp uh to ask for another
referendum which is their uh their
habitual uh refrain they they
that is all they seem able uh to talk
about uh
democratic uh wrangling about uh
democracy and
their desire to to be separated uh and
to break up
the country i don't think that's the
right way forward i think we need strong
defenses
uh that's what the people of this
country voted for and that's what we're
going to deliver
let's go to steve bryant steve
thank you mr speaker from from gloom to
joy and uh
news from the winchester for the prime
minister is that the vaccination program
is going
really really well there are now less
than 200 000 people in the whole of
hampshire in the isle of wight left to
do in cohorts one to nine
we have the the plan plus the supply to
cover them comfortably by the end of
march
so with my rightful friend please thank
the nhs and its volunteers here for this
amazing effort and as he does that
could he share with us his view on what
led to the disinformation
and apparent abandonment of scientific
evidence in certain eu member states
around the oxford astrazeneca jab
prime minister i want to of course i
thank the
uh the nhs in uh in hampshire and indeed
around the country for the amazing job
that they're doing in rolling out the
vaccination program it's been truly
stunning and i think perhaps the best
thing i can say about
um uh the oxford uh vaccine
uh program is that uh i'm i've finally
got news that i'm going to have my own
uh jab mr speaker very very shortly i'm
pleased to uh discover i'm
i don't know whether the right
honourable gentleman's had his he's had
it uh but but it will certainly
be oxford astrazeneca that i will be
having
let's go to garand davis
mr speaker there's now been over 600
cases of coronavirus infections at dvla
swansea since september yet ministers
still refuse to meet with the pcs union
to discuss
ways in which workers more workers can
work from home
in safety before they're vaccinated so
workers have now resorted to
voting for strike action as a last
resort to protect their families and
communities
so i asked the prime minister again will
he now instruct
ministers to engage in talks with the
union to help
shield vulnerable workers before
vaccination
or will he force a needless strike
prime minister why i think needless is
is the right word mr speaker
and i think he should bear in mind that
any strike is likely to be bad news for
motorists uh we're at the stage now we
want to have
uh advancing down our roadmap out of out
of lockdown and at the dvla
uh any staff who can work from home are
doing so and currently out of a
workforce of of six thousand
only uh five cases of covid
uh have currently been found and i
understand that those individuals
are all working from home so frankly mr
speaker i see no need for industrial
action
thank you mr speaker my kensington
constituents and i
have been deeply troubled by what is
coming out of the grenfell
inquiry with regard to the building
products
industry does my right honorable friend
agree with me that contractors
who have behaved improperly should not
be used going forward for government
contracts
and will my right honorable friend
consider
a tax on the building products industry
in the same way as we've done on the
residential property sector
as a way for partly paying for cladding
remediation
i mentioned uh i i thank my honorable
friend and i know how
how much she cares about this issue and
how deeply her constituents have been
affected by the
the grenfell fire and um what i can say
to her i will study her
proposal for a a new tax uh on building
uh materials and uh i know my right-hand
befriend the chancellor
uh will want to think about that kind of
idea but we are looking at
new rules to exclude contractors
from government business uh where gross
professional
negligence has been shown mr speaker
let's go to richard bergen richard
exactly one year ago today we were told
that 20 000 coronavirus deaths would be
and i quote a good outcome yet our death
toll
is now six times higher over a hundred
thousand more people
have lost their lives than that initial
estimate
in march last year the prime minister
pontificated about
taking it on the chin others acted
decisively
with lockdowns but the prime minister
dithered
and delayed with deadly consequences
with the worst hopefully now behind us
isn't it time for the prime minister
to hold up his hands and come clean with
the british public
and say those deaths are on me
and for that i apologize
prime minister well mr speaker i i
certainly take full responsibility for
everything the government uh did and uh
of course uh we
mourn uh the loss of every single uh
coronavirus victim
uh and uh we sympathize deeply with
their
with their families and and their and
their loved ones
and am i sorry for what has happened
to our country yes of course i'm deeply
uh deeply sorry mr speaker and of course
there will be
uh time uh for a a full inquiry to
enable us
all uh to understand uh what we need to
do better
uh when we face these problems in the
future and that is uh
something i think the whole house shows
let's go to dr neil hudson
thank you mr speaker five years on from
storm desmond and a year on from storm
kiara
sadly penrith and the border and cumbria
remain in the front line for severe
flooding events
with climate change these catastrophes
are becoming
increasingly frequent and severe and the
effects on communities are serious and
long
term can my right honourable friend
reassure my constituents that at-risk
communities will be supported by
government
both in terms of flood protection but
also with the longer term support
including
in the important area of help for the
mental health
impacts of flooding prime minister
uh my honorable friend makes a really
good point about the mental health
impacts of flooding anybody who
goes to oh he's been a victim of
flooding or who visits a family that's
been hit by flooding will know the
immense distress
that flooding uh causes and that's why
the nhs will
uh get an extra 500 million pounds uh to
address
uh those issues and to give more support
uh for
the for the mental health needs that
people have this twist
thank you mr speaker prime minister in
december 2019's election campaign
you visited samantha parker at her home
in darlington
samantha has the rare genetic condition
pku
you vowed to do your utmost to get her
access to the life-changing drug
kuvang on the nhs we can't use you i'm
not responsible
thank you apologies um the prime
minister vowed to do his utmost to get
her access to the life changing drug
cuva
last month nice published draft guidance
which would make kuvan available to
children
but not to adults like samantha great
for children but devastating and
discriminatory
for adults like samantha prime minister
speaking as chair of the appg on pku
i now ask what action will you take to
deliver on your commitment to samantha
vancouver
and make unavailable for her and for
other adults
with pku i thank her very much for
raising
uh the case which i i will remember i'm
glad
uh that knight has now extended uh the
uh the treatments availability to to
children with pku
uh i clearly we need to to do more and i
will i will be very happy to take it up
but it's a better jenkins thank you mr
speaker has my right honourable friend
noted
that the integrated review has been
widely and rightly welcomed
as a bold british vision for our role in
the world
at the same time but not in scotland of
course where the
nationalist administration is thinks
it's more important to put indie ref 2
on the ballot paper those scottish
elections does he realize that they are
rejecting
the jobs and security that this his
review guarantees in scotland because
they hate the uk
more than uh they want jobs for their
own people
prime minister um well i i'm grateful to
my my right honourable friend for his
support for the integrated review
um i i think that uh
i i i hard to know what motivates uh our
friends in the scottish
national party but i do think that
they're mistaken
uh in uh in their approach to this i
think that
uh we're better as one uh united kingdom
uh i think that we're stronger together
as one
united kingdom and i think the
contribution of
uh the people of scotland to uh the
defense of our united kingdom is
absolutely incredible and has been
uh for centuries and uh that's what i
want to maintain and i think it's a it's
a it's a fine thing and they should
champion it
let's go to halle tahia
did i hear holly throughout the last
year
nhs staff have been working tirelessly
to keep our communities
healthy and safe during the pandemic
mr speaker i would like to ask the prime
minister
why has he been economical with the
truth when he says that a one percent
pay increase is all the government can
afford
can i just say no honourable member on
any side would actually
mislead or lie to the house but i'm sure
the premise could answer something
thank you mr speaker no i i'm grateful
for your clarification because
um what what we're doing is we're saying
that we
so value the incredible contribution of
nurses to
our country over the last year or more
uh that we want them exceptionally of
all the public services
uh to be looked at uh for for a pay
increase at a time
of real uh difficulty in the public
finances which i think people do
understand
now uh that's on top of the the 12.8
percent increase in starting salary
for nurses plus the uh
the the five thousand pounds bursary in
the three thousand pounds that we've
given
for uh special help for uh for
child care and and and other training
needs
and which actually are leading if he
looks at the figures
uh they're leading to a big increase in
the number of nurses
uh in in the nhs 10 600 more this year
than last year more nurses
in the nhs and 60 000 more in training
and when i talk to nurses
what they want of course everybody wants
better paying conditions i totally
understand that
but what they also want is an extra pair
of hands
next to them to give them the help and
reassurance they need and that's what
we're recruiting
the king thank you mr speaker
recent horrific events have brought the
important debate
on women and girls rights into the
spotlight
and specifically their right to be safe
and feel safe as they go about their
daily
lives does my right honourable friend
agree
that such issues need to be treated
sensitively and false claims made
by the labour party last night on social
media
about the police crimes sentencing a
courts bill are misleading
and certainly not helpful
prime minister ah well mr speaker i
think it was
it was certainly uh a a mistake and a
regrettable mistake
for anybody to suggest that rape had
been decriminalized in this country
uh because uh because we must do
everything we can
to reassure victims of rape and sexual
violence and get them
to come forward and that is what we're
doing and i also think it would be a
good thing
if together uh we could vote for some of
the tougher
sentences that we put forward in this
bill and
i like the collegiate spirit that uh we
had earlier on i hope it could be
extended
to voting for the tougher sentences that
we put forward no question george
thank you very much mr speaker today the
welsh labor government announced a
special bonus payment
for nhs and social care staff in wales
with the welsh government covering
the basic tax and national insurance
payments that most people will receive
around 500 pounds will the prime
minister today
join me in welcoming this payment in
recognition of the dedication
and commitment by nhs and social care
staff
prime minister i i thank him and i i i
do indeed recognize the amazing
dedication and commitment of
of nhs and social care staff uh who have
been at the forefront of this
uh pandemic who've borne the brunt of it
uh in many cases
personally in the in their lives and
that's why i just repeat the point that
i
i made a little a while ago about what
we're doing to recognize
uh the contribution of nurses in
particular
alone of all uh the public sector in
these very very difficult times
and to say how uh relieved and glad i am
to see
the number of nurses who are now uh in
trading i think there's a 34
increase in applications to be nurses
this year in the country uh that's great
but we're going to drive it forward mr
speaker we want to go
as you know we have a target of 50 000
more nurses as well as 20 000
more police i'm suspending the house for
three
minutes to enable the necessary
arrangements for the next business
order
well uh that was the end of prime
minister's questions let's bring in our
political editor beth rigby who joins us
now from westminster
beth we did think that uh the death of
sarah everett and the events
of the last week would very much feature
and it certainly didn't it
yes that's right jane and there was
quite a powerful opening there wasn't
there from cirque
stammer as he talked about the murder of
sarah everett being a watershed moment
for the country and and for many women
and girls who feel harassed who are
suffering
violence against them and he asked the
prime minister did he agree it was a
watershed moment and did he agree
agree that it was a turning point in
which
things had to actually change and the
prime minister
was very open to that he said that he
agreed
uh with kierstarma about that and he
talked about
uh this being that he understood
the outcry about women's safety and said
we need a cultural and social change
in this country something the prime
minister repeated a couple of times
uh during the questions and then when it
actually came
uh to cirque stammer giving the prime
minister his set of
questions it was really into the detail
as i was saying earlier about this
10-point plan
that labor has put forward on the matter
of
violence against women and girls and
what sort of action
in terms of policy and law that could
come about he began to ask the prime
minister
on specific issues so he asked him about
whether he would put
a timetable down for a victims bill
this is whereby women and other victims
of sexual violence would be guaranteed
the right legally uh for support
for and and for social services support
uh to help them deal with the crimes
against them
the starkey asked the prime minister if
he would actually you know come to the
table and put
that through the house of commons he
also asked him about
toughest sentencing in action against
crimes uh such as rape now when you look
at
rape uh convictions they are now at an
all-time
low there were over 55 000
uh cases of rape reported last year and
only
less than 1500 actual convictions so
it gives you a sense of the scale of the
problem in terms of actually
people being brought to justice on the
matter
of rape so that was again another issue
raised by sarkistarma
now where did the prime minister end up
with this well he said he was open such
suggestions
he reminded the leader of the opposition
that the government is itself going to
bring forward a strategy
of violence to deal with violence
against women and girls later
this year but he wouldn't be bounced
into any committing to any specific
measures at pmq's
yes today but what it did show you is
that in terms of an actual
programme for change the labour party is
definitely going to be pushing that and
the